clip your nails and strap your uncle to
the bed because it's episode 4 of the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina and it's
time to get schooled Sabrina and her
friends enjoy some quality time at
doctor services discussing the symbolism
of body dysmorphia and STDs in the fly
you know typical teenager stuff Roz's
old let's have a girls night but Sabrina
is all I'm helping my Aunt Hilda sell
her honey but really she's got her
weekend sleepover at the Academy
Harvey's like combing the second you get
back I'll come right over can they
smooch for an uncomfortable amount of
time in front of their friends back at
home Ambrose watches Sabrina pack for
the weekend at the academy he calls it
her induction where she'll get to meet
many interesting witches and warlocks
some of them may even be hot but
Sabrina's not going to the Academy to
hook up with hot warlocks she's there to
learn how to conjure bind and banish the
dark lord himself the morning of
Sabrina's first day Hilda packs with her
some protection charms to ward off the
bullies she even suggests bringing Salem
but Zelda says that's only for babies
and ninnies Sabrina takes a nice
relaxing walk along the train tracks and
comes to a building with the writing
Gehenna station Gehenna is a small
valley in Jerusalem where according to
the Hebrew Bible the kings of Judah
sacrificed their children by fire in the
King James version of the Bible it
literally translates to the word hell
and you thought your high school was
hell at the front door sabrina is
greeted by children of the corn kid
Quintin he shows her around the Academy
each room designed according to the
principles of sacred geometry and shaped
as a perfectly proportioned Pentagon
apparently no one knows exactly how many
rooms there are she's greeted by Faustus
who's ready to put all the bitterness of
the trial behind him and hand sabrina
her schedule but after one look sabrina
isn't too happy where all the cool
classes she's supposed to be taking like
conjuring demonology and binding the
Dark Lord for dummies apparently there
are prerequisites but first she must
master the sacred art of choir practice
in dark glee club the choir sings I'll
never say never - always a song by the
family jams aka members of the cult of
Charles Manson the choir teacher is yep
Faustus Blackwood's wife and she tests
Sabrina on her singing abilities and boy
oh boy does she sing that cult leader
song beautifully this totally pisses off
prudence who's
competition for the solo at nationals
and oh look one of those hot guys
Ambrose mentioned at lunch hot choir guy
introduces himself as dick scratch I
mean Nick scratch he sits down for the
typical witch lunch of green beans and
mac and cheese and mentions he's a big
fan of her father's work he gets to read
all of his journals in the sanctum a
library only for advanced students it's
under lock and key and you can't even
take notes typical they then get a visit
from the plastics of the Academy who sit
down to talk trash why do you have to be
such a [ __ ] all the time
why'd you have to be such a warlock [ __ ]
all the time Sabrina's won this battles
but it looks like the weird sisters are
preparing for war at Susie's rosin Sue's
have a slumber party and watch Carnival
of Souls when a bell rings upstairs
turns out Susie's Uncle Jesse has moved
in from Full House in his sick in bed he
only rings however when he needs
something when they go to check on him
all they hear is heavy breathing gross
apparently Uncle Jesse went crazy in the
mines after seeing something some
monster remind you of anyone and he's
been acting strange ever since the Blood
Moon back at the academy Sabrina's
awoken by Quinten he comes with a
warning don't show them you're scared or
they'll kill you on the spot before
Sabrina finds herself in a dark cell
enter the weird sisters who are making
Sabrina undergo the harrowing
essentially the Academy's form of hazing
they've locked Sabrina away in the cells
the original Greendale 13 were held in
remember the vision from Episode one of
the hanging witches Sabrina will have to
endure what they did no Sun no food most
witches went mad and cut their own
throats Sabrina will have to spend the
night without going insane when Sabrina
cries for help it's kitty Salem who
hears her call and comes to protect her
through the night but the hazing isn't
done the weird sisters have stolen Salem
along with Sabrina's PJs so she'll have
to endure her harrowing without the
protection of her familiar or warm
snuggly clothes for bed the two then
engage in a catfight and by that I mean
a fight over Sabrina's cat before being
interrupted by Faustus holding Salem in
a cage Zelda comes in for a
parent-teacher meeting over Sabrina's
behavior first Salem has got to go but
secondly Faustus wonders if Sabrina is
happy here what a gent Sabrina wants to
take conjuring classes like her father
but Faustus won't let her until
she believes she's ready to prove she's
ready Sabrina will have to solve her
father's Acheron configuration
essentially a witch's puzzle that not
only challenges your mind but also your
will solve it or go mad trying
Faustus sends out Sabrina to chat with
Zelda in private
lady Blackwood has had two miscarriages
and he would like Zelda to be her
midwife she hasn't done it in years but
reluctantly agrees outside the Academy
Sabrina runs into hot Nick apparently he
had a love square with the Weird Sisters
and might be able to talk some sense
into them he also fills Sabrina in on
the history of the Acheron it was his
father's thesis and Blackwood's been
trying to solve it for twenty years
the more you stare at it the harder it
is to solve but if this is her father's
creation maybe Sabrina is just the
person to crack it but only if Nick can
smuggle her into the library to take a
look at her dad's journals back in the
mortal world Roz less harvey in on the
story of Uncle Jesse and Harvey learns
he's not the only one who saw something
in the minds Ambrose gets a call from
Luke asking him out on a coffee date
however being under house arrest makes
this a little hard and he'll need help
from Aunt Hilda to astral project there
but it's risky only the dead are allowed
to travel the astral plane if he takes
too long the psycho pumps will find him
and haul him off into the hereafter or
worse tattled to the dweller in ancient
Egyptian and Greek mythology psycho
pumps are creatures or spirits that
escort the dead from earth to the
afterlife they do not judge they simply
guide and it is often said they appear
as a bird and then again as a flock of
birds outside the homes of the
soon-to-be dead but after Zelda barges
in and insults Hilda she agrees to help
at the academy miss ward well pops in
for a visit with Blackwood where he
gives her the idea to go have some fun
with Sabrina's auntie's while she's away
and they're vulnerable
Hilda and Ambrose prepare for his astral
projection date Ambrose chants wolle any
map RA Terra na which is Latin for fly
through eternal life and pop he's nice
and early for his date totally better
than tinder then right on cue the
doorbell rings and it's miss ward well
here to scope the place out I mean make
funeral arrangements
Hilda asked her to wait for a moment so
she can go check on Ambrose and you know
make sure he doesn't die Luke shows up
for the date but Ambrose finds it's hard
to focus as he starts seeing psycho
pumps we learned the craziest thing
Ambrose ever did was try to blow up the
Hakan likely why he's under house arrest
well Hilda's downstairs miss ward well
starts exploring taking Sabrina's hair
and her fingernails by the way I thought
I was the only one who kept their
fingernails in a glass bowl in their
room she then gives Sabrina's Mira wet
willy so she can spy on her
but her tour of the spellman house is
cut short once Alda returns more psycho
pumps appear which forces Ambrose -
literally ghost Luke check out the
poster for Carnival of Souls here the
same movie Roz and Susie were watching
back at the Academy night - means it's
time for another harrowing the weird
sisters lead Sabrina on the same path
the Greendale 13 took to be hanged hung
hanged I don't know the story goes if
they dared lift their gaze to meet
immortals they were stoned on the spot
tearing - will require Sabrina to stare
at the hanging tree and never look back
until dawn she hears the voice of Harvey
behind her but doesn't look he gets
ripped to shreds she hears the voice of
her mom also ripped to shreds then it's
her dad which seems to have the greatest
effect on some rip to shreds and then
dawn and little Quentin comes to get her
guiding her to a grave in the woods his
own grave this graveyard is the burial
place of all the children who were
killed during a harrowing talk about
some hardcore hazing
Sabrina gives Zelda and Hilda a call to
fill them in the to rush to the Academy
to inform Blackwood who is less than
accommodating here we see the first real
sign of Zelda straying away from
Blackwood's loyalty and siding with
Sabrina and the trio go to visit the
children of the forest the children are
bound to the Academy because they died
there but they don't want to be freed
they want some good old-fashioned
revenge and Hilda's got a plan new you
had some evil in your hildie at Susie's
place Harvey visits to try and have a
talk with Uncle Jesse about the mines
either that or play a game of operation
but when he goes to ask Jesse he's been
possessed
he gives Harvey one of these before
Susie bunks him on the head with a water
Tim after the experience with The Herald
children Zelda realizes how horribly
she's treated her sister in school and
offers to extend their bedtime and real
night 3:00 at the academy and you
guessed it it's time for the last
harrowing this time the sisters ain't
messing around and drag Serena towards
the hanging tree with a frickin noose
around her neck this harrowing just
seems like a downright execution
prudence throws the noose over a tree
branch and says any last words no task
of an
pterence or hard stipulation for
survival just a we're straight-up gonna
kill you
Sabrina's last words condemn the sisters
saying that Greendale 13 would never
have turned on each other like what
they're doing which is why it ends
tonight that's when the Harrow children
show up chanting light as a feather
stiff as a board the saying comes from a
popular children's game often played at
slumber parties one person lies on the
floor while everyone else tries to lift
them using only their fingertips and
chanting light as a feather stiff as a
board
more recently it became popularized in
the film the craft a story of four young
women as they familiarize themselves
with witchcraft in all scenarios this
chant often accompanies levitation and
up they go the sisters are hung around
the tree only to be let go if they agree
to never Harrow again if you say another
thing about my mother and father to
anyone ever again
death on your own meanwhile Roz Susie
and Harvey make their always smart
choice to go back into the room with the
demon man and find him going all
exorcist on the bed the Academy on the
other hand is back to normal the ghosts
of The Herald are staying to make sure
no one ever does it again and Nick stops
by to give Sabrina one of her dad's
journals he smuggled from the library
hook dick scratch in Blackwood's office
we learned prudence and the sisters were
under the orders of Faustus himself and
though the Dark Lord wants Sabrina here
he never said she couldn't suffer miss
ward well gives one more wet willy to
her mirror only to find Sabrina on a
call with Harvey talking about how much
they love each other but Sabrina's got
acheron homework to do so she opens up
her father's journal in it there all
sorts of notes and strange engravings as
well as a drawing of her mother as
Sabrina folds the following pages with
the creases in them the corners reveal
the letters dia na Diana her mother
under that are drawings of the Acheron
that can only be seen with the pages
folded Sabrina takes one more look at
the drawing of her mother
notice that the eyes are closed and then
attempts to open the Acheron while doing
the same and voila it works and out pops
some strange orange powder what
surprises could this spring oh you know
just a mutilated claw creature and with
that we end the episode thanks for
watching guys as always if you liked the
video please give it a like trying to
get the Sabrina video
and as fast as possible so stay tuned
for more see you next time on the path
of night